yeah okay thank you professor duster my
name is 0 yamaguchi it's a great honor
to
participating in to this class from
Tokyo and it's all not to talk about
technical and new partnership with
United wind so let me start with quick
introduction of TEPCO can you go to the
next slide please ok so a quick
introduction of a typical well in Japan
there are 10 incumbent utilities and
typical is the largest armed with 29
million customers in the Tokyo area and
it accounts for about third of Japan's
total electricity demand so after the
Fukushima nuclear accident and crisis of
marg 11 2011 things have changed
drastically fo typical because we became
virtually bankrupt after the crisis and
we are nationalized by the Japanese
government now although as far as stable
supply of electricity is concerned we
have a world's highest reliability of
electricity and we provide technical
expertise to all over the world for
instance we do various consulting
projects or 600 projects for 70
countries in the last 10 years so next
slide please so let me touch on quickly
about the progress on just a second
we're getting blank on I'm saying blank
on your slide through down there we go
thank you thank you so let me just to
touch on the progress in hookah shima
decommissioning and decontamination so
as you know do two gigantic earthquake
and tsunami all the power was lost in
who kashima and four reactors suffered
meltdown but as you can see in the
pictures we have made a remarkable
progress and reactors are stable he
cooled and preparations for spent fuel
and Avery's removal are in progress at
Fukushima so the next slide please this
is the organizational structure of TEPCO
we are just shifted to a holding company
structure in april of this year
so we have the holding company and below
that we have three major subsidiary
companies so holding company is
basically responsible for Fukushima dnd
decontamination and decommissioning and
also who became a revitalization and
also compensation to the victims of the
accident I'll also restart of the
remaining nuclear power stations but
also one of the important function of
the Holy companies to is promotion of
renewable energy and also innovations
and R&D related to that and as a
subsidiary we have set up a few on
thermal power generation company and a
transmission distribution company and
the retail company as you can see and
fulfilled on through thermal power
generation if you click on other yeah we
have formed a alliance with a chubu
electric company that is a no-go year in
Japan and we we will as for the field
procurement from the power we will merge
into this new company called gerra so
general week a new company responsible
for fuel procurement and domestic and
international thermal power generation
business okay next slide so let me just
explain about the electricity system
reform on deregulation in Japan so in 9
2015 we have already set up a
organizations quite similar to
independent system operators up in the
US and in 2016 April as I said full day
rate deregulation of the regional market
has been attained well Japan's retail
market deregulation beginning year 2000
so it took 16 years to deregulate the
whole market in Japan and well legal
structural unbundling is required to all
incumbent electric utilities by 2020 so
we are sort of kind of catching up with
the u.s. in terms of deregulation
if Nick's like peas before before we go
to that younger son can I ask you say
that the full deregulation of the retail
market does that mean that there will be
other private providers of retail
electricity in Japan is that is correct
okay ah yeah so regional competitions
are opened so customers residential
customers can choose any supplier other
than typical and there are more than
hundred new suppliers energy but we call
it by PBS's but the do our supplies who
are in the market thank you know we
already have another competition typical
has already lost about 1 billion
customers so that's a big churn okay
thank you very much for the
clarification okay so so this slide
explains that power demand sales is a
declining due to population decline in
Japan and also energy conservation in
Japan and of course our competition so
we have a shrinking market in Japan so
that is why TEPCO is looking at at the
international market for growth
especially the Asian market where there
is still expected on the growth of in
Asian countries so next slide this is a
slide that shows the energy mix before
box 11 2011 and what happened after so
before about 11 2011 we had a sort of a
balanced energy mix as you can see
nuclear playing a big role as a base
load of power but after the crisis of
2011 we lost all of the nuclear power
stations after that so as you can see in
the year 2014 we had to significantly
increase our reliance on fossil fuels
like we call LNG and the typical much of
importing or buying most expensive
energies are in
world so as you can see on slide 20 30
there's a plan government plan to sort
of restart turtles the nuclear power
stations with meaning we have a
remaining nuclear power station called
kk kashiwazaki-kariwa in Niigata
Prefecture but we do not know when it
will get restarted so as you can see we
have to increase the proportion of
nuclear arsenal renewable part renewable
which is the blue pot on the other top
well while we're on the slide let me ask
all of the oil and all of the LNG is
imported from abroad right yes almost
all of the fossil fuels are imported
including the coal including cone yeah
okay yeah we have we'll start by
importing from the US as well but and we
basically import mainly from Middle East
countries and also asian countries on
australia okay thank you so as for
renewables the japanese energy policy
shifted to promote renewables after the
crisis of 2011 so just like maybe not
the US but just like european countries
we introduced a feed-in tariff system in
july 2012 and so the installed capacity
of renewables has been increasing in a
rapid pace we don't have the numbers in
the graph but for instance the installed
capacity of renewable energy was like
1.5 gigawatt in 2011 but now it's a
close to 10 gigawatts and we're looking
at like more than 20 gigawatts like
20-30 so we Japan as an energy policy we
are going to increase renewables for
energy security reasons so the next
slide okay so this slide shows a for big
trends that are going on in the energy
industry in the world which starts with
with addy i'll just namely deregulation
decentralization decarbonisation and
digitalization so deregulation
I talked about the full market the
competition in Japan us and england is a
handy deregulation and Europe and in
Asian countries we see that it's a major
countries are I started deregulation so
this is a worldwide trade trend and the
second decentralization this is a
basically distributed energy resources
is increasing what I mean that
photovoltaics batteries the other
sources of energy is distributed so
we're changing form a centralized power
system to a distributed power system and
the third one is e carbonization as i
said the renewables is increasing even
in Japan but die it's increasing at a
more rapid pace in u.s. England China
and other places let's look at that
solar wind biomass another other stuff
and the last one is a digitalization so
I to IT technology is changing the
energy industry for instance there are a
lot of intelligent software that
controls those distributed energy
resources which enables a totally
different world from shift from
centralized power to decentralize power
so drastic transformation and change is
going on in the energy industry around
the world and also disruption is going
on so that is why we need to proactively
act a local companies these challenges
our next slide please ok to keep on
pushing keep pushing yeah thank you okay
this is good yeah so we have started to
invest in innovative companies in the US
and looking for companies in India as
well so the investment thesis is is
there lately renewables microgrids
storage technologies and disruptive
technologies like blockchain
visual intelligence and data analytics
so we believe that is will change the
way we do business so would you call
this corporate venture capital or is
this more investment through joint
ventures and business partnerships it's
both okay yeah it's both okay so yeah so
typical so my team is uh it's promoting
these investments and innovation and
trying to disrupt ourselves before we
get disrupted by someone else so I'll so
PR okay so thanks very much you do have
a slide on the Gantner ship or shall we
go to damn oh yeah I LA basin after
afterwards okay so we'll come back to
your presentation after we see Dan's
presentation Brianna keep that kind of
handy okay they have the floors yours
and can you hear me in Japan as I have a
magnitude III and we can see you all
right well thank you everyone and thank
you a professor Dasher for having me I'm
a very excited to be here today and
introduce United wind and the setting
partnership that we've formed here with
TEPCO you know our our vision and our
goal United wind has has been consistent
over time as the company's evolved and
its really to provide an affordable
clean energy to millions of property
owners globally and we're starting to
see that more and more through
partnerships performing much like the
one we'll talk about today with with
TEPCO a little bit about United wind and
i'll even go before the history that
this slide touches on but United wind
started as a software technology company
it was really it was a company called
wind analytics and had developed a
software tool that allowed based on a
specific latitude and longitude to
predict with fairly high degree of
accuracy what the wind resource would be
on a specific residential location and
the reason for that was there are a lot
of historically in the you
market rural customers who had on-site
wind generation is not a new technology
but what was new was that those
customers weren't necessarily getting
the best quality they weren't knowing
how much power was going to be produced
and so the software tool allowed
customers who wanted to pursue that
technology to have some way to to
quantify what the benefits would be what
we realize is that moving from there
forward it was a software tool that
didn't have a lot of pull with it and in
order to kind of help pull and bundle
that software tool we decided to pair it
with a combination with an installer and
so a best-in-class installer and wind
analytics company called telco and wind
analytics merged and formed United win
in about twenty thirteen so then under
the United wind umbrella we had this
software tool and the capability to
install and then further to increase the
velocity and throughput we added on to
that a financing component and that's
what's created United wind as it stands
today and really the objective is to be
a full suite development and asset
management company that focuses on a
specific asset distributed wind energy
machines that we operate today are on
the smaller scale 10 to 100 kW but we
have plans to go up to as much as 900 KW
and we are responsible for all the asset
management over the full life of the
wind lease which is 20 years and I'll
get into that but the value proposition
is not just the financing where we cover
all the upfront costs it's that we
provide them to a customer by having a
savings over time and in addition to
that we guarantee the performance of the
asset over the term of the lease and
that value proposition resonated with a
lot of strategic investors here tepco
being one of them and a lot of that was
driven by our ability we have now for
funds where we deploy capital into these
projects so United Windows raise
corporate capital and is raised project
level capital as well and so these are
the investors within those different
segments
this is the value proposition that I
started to talk about where basically
when we approach a customer we identify
them based on in the United States using
the software tool what will be a good
wind resource area we then further drill
down into what r the rate tariffs in
those areas which customers have enough
land for us to pursue the development of
one of these turbines on and then we
approach them with what effectively is a
wind quote that wind quotes shows them
how much they're paying now and under a
wind lease what their value proposition
would be between the wind lease payment
and the remaining electricity bill and
that leads to the remaining savings and
so over the life we see that there's
really savings of around twenty five
percent if not more and our systems
depending on in the US the net metering
rules and regulations will power
anywhere between 70 50 70 up to and over
a hundred percent of the load at the
customer's property dan before you go on
let me ask a quick question sure
basically in these projects Oh United
wind actually provides the turbine and
the customer just Lisa's the service of
having it on the property and the power
and so forth the capital costs for
putting in the turbine is is something
that you bear that's correct so United
wind covers one hundred percent of the
upfront cost effectively financing the
system for the customer and that's one
of the pillars of value that we offer so
there's the technical value proposition
of this the actual technical piece of
equipment and then there's the financial
value proposition that we offer and the
next slide here shows a little bit about
all the different divisions within
united wind you know unlike some of the
behind the meter distributed solar
generation companies which is what we
assimilate to most when we compare
ourselves comp-wise to other companies
we have all in-house
capabilities of doing the construction
installation in the OM a lot of times
that's out sourced given the nascence e
of the industry in the United States
what we found is we have actually
acquired the company that we outsource
to before and found that we're able to
do the installations on a much much
cheaper scale so it's actually helpful
for us from a margin standpoint so
everything from the sails to the wind
analysis providing the financing and
then doing the installation and
long-term maintenance but those are all
components and the customer to your
point professor Dasher really just signs
the wind lease which obligates them to
make monthly payments that are
consistent for the next 20 years but in
return for that we take care of
everything for them okay this is uh I
don't know how well it comes out I guess
on the big screen here gives you a
representative sample of our portfolio
which currently is in New York we have
portfolio that that sort of is in
different points of development fully
placed in service what we call when it's
under operation assets in construction
assets and development at the time of
this slide it always sort of I try and
have it updated before I speak each time
but we had nothing that was credit
pending which was nice and we usually
try and maintain a very healthy pipeline
in this case in New York this fund is
our third fund and we will likely close
out the third fund in in 2017 and we've
already raised our fourth fund which
will be around 200 million dollars that
will deploy and I'll talk about that in
the Midwest and then obviously looking
looking very much at international
markets through through through TEPCO
and seeing what we can do there this
gives an example of the type of
technology these range in size from
small 10 kilowatt systems to as large as
nine hundred kilowatts almost a megawatt
the type of customer profile that we
would use behind each of these would be
very different
the 10 kilowatt would be of you know
much much similar to a residential type
of customer whereas 900 you're getting
to a fairly large commercial industrial
customer but all of these are certified
approved customers the technology is
what I'm referring to and we go through
a pretty rigorous technology review
process internally that allows us to
make the technology financeable and
bankable that's important for us in our
fund so we review and go through a
fairly extensive vetting process with
independent engineers and visiting sites
and existing turbines and so forth to
get a feel for how they're operating the
wind analytics software as I mentioned
is something that we continue to use
today this is sort of the core of where
United wind started it again it's built
on analysis of algorithms and software
that we take based on triangulating
existing weather data stations cleaning
up the data and then accounting for
obstructions and so forth between where
those towers are and where the site is
that we're going to place a turbine on
that allows us to use this sort of
sighting location and come up with
fairly predictive analysis as to how the
wind will blow over time and can
therefore guarantee to the customer what
we feel the performance will be of the
asset over the 20-year lease okay it's a
fairly boring page but this is our
typical lease a lot of customers are
always very focused on this in the
beginning it's a 20-year lease at the
end of the lease they have several
options they can either choose to renew
the lease which is the most likely
scenario since its built it's there and
they're happy with it they have the
option as well to purchase the turbine
on their own and take over control they
can request it to be removed there's a
cost sharing mechanism associated with
that the fourth option is that they may
choose to
abandon it and allow us to sell the
power at that point on a wholesale basis
to the local utility is a qualified
facility in the United States they're
also again very simplistic question
they're paying you a flat rental fee and
their income would be variable depending
on on how much wind actually comes in
through the turbine because they are
able to get I guess most of the revenue
from selling the wind to the power
company your customers are so in the
United States where we operate there is
a concept called net metering and so the
customer when the wind is blowing and
the customer is using electricity they
are using the electricity first from
from the wind turbine to the extent that
they're not using electricity or their
load is not requiring all of it then
there's this net metering concept where
the the electrons flow back to the grid
and the customer gets full retail credit
for those those electrons so they're
effectively reducing their bill as their
you know effectively not home okay
thanks yeah otherwise the the
obligations are primarily live with us
as the less or of the equipment were
obligated to ensure the system repair it
maintain it for the full 20 years and
take over and provide effectively a
long-term production guarantee so that
they're sure as to how much they will
learn over that period of time okay
these are our funds that I was alluding
to we had started early on with very
small funds for the proof of concept
behind what it is we're doing that then
led to larger funds with more
institutional investors and that then
brought in more and more institutional
corporate capital to fund the platform
these are two different types of
financing structures that we use in the
United States one is very simple single
investor lease where we would develop
the assets we would sell them to an
investor who would take both the tax
benefits and cash benefits that the
projects would produce in the other case
here under a partnership flip it's more
complicated tax structure this is unique
to the US market where the US market
incentivizes renewable energy with a
combination of tax credits and cash
abroad as as I understand in Japan and
in many countries in Europe there's a
more simplified feed-in tariff structure
which actually makes the financing a
little bit easier in the United States
you have to have specific type of income
to shelter for tax benefits depending on
the type of project that's going up and
for that we have partnerships with big
institutional tax players like US bank
that I showed on the previous page that
allow us to monetize those benefits when
we monetize those benefits those
customers invest in the project when
they invest in the project we can reduce
the cost of the lease payment that the
customer pays so simple way to think
about it is we harvest these benefits
and we pass on the savings to the
customer good and this is the pipeline
that we're looking at right now in the
United States so as you can see we're
moving away from New York we're moving
more into the Midwest and that's really
just driven by the fact that that's
where the best wind resources in the
United States and we we see that we're
really not competing with these behind
the meter solar companies because they
tend to play on the coasts where there
is a very good win a good solar resource
when it comes to competing head on it
really depends on how good the solar
radiance is versus the wind in the
Midwest we find that the cost of
electricity we can provide many times
can actually beat that of solar because
of the fact that the wind is so strong
and this is where we see broadly market
opportunities in the u.s. it's in a
multiple billions of dollars of
opportunity and we're sort of just
scratching the surface in the beginning
here and that is a couple members of our
team that's really you know what I have
I'm I can reserve comment as far as with
TEPCO the partnership but it's whenever
you would like I can get into that too
okay we'll talk about that in just a
minute Briana I'm going to ask you if
you will switch presentations back to
Young Gucci sons presentation again
because I want to first ask about this
partnership really kind of from the way
it looks to TEPCO why is TEPCO getting
involved in this now we're just on the
floor is yours again oh ok so as I
explained in Japan we have a tremendous
challenges in energy mix we don't know
when the nuclear will ever start it
might not start and also as I said we
are buying the most expensive Ellen
disease from the Middle East so well as
a well energy security standpoint we
need to make use of every kind of
renewable resources in Japan we have we
typical already has a couple of
utility-scale wind turbine generation in
Japan almost stopped one gigawatt so we
have been sort of utilizing big wind
turbines already and also as for sola
they're not of photovoltaics not typical
but not of housing as solo actually I
have to say this has been something that
I've really noticed the last few times
I've flown in to narita airport you see
lots of the small you know field size
solar arrays that you know they're
springing up like mushrooms instead of
rice
now have solar arrays that's right so
photovoltaics are rapidly increasing and
the reason for that there's a dimension
because of the feed-in tariff prices in
Japan this is the government's at a
pretty high feed-in tariff pricing 2012
to promote renewable so so is increasing
and large-scale wind utility is
increasing but we did not have a
small-scale winter visit in Japan that
is probably because it's difficult to
predict how much when there is and as
long as you know this some you know your
software like with analytics so that the
United win has yeah you know unity we
didn't have we cannot have any sort of
sort of scientific scientific evidence
and maybe you've got a slide on this
brianna move one slide next slide okay
one there we go this is it is now yeah
yeah yeah yeah and what I was going to
ask is one reason I think for the
extremely large turbines that you see in
Japan is the power production was
relatively centralized right and they're
really of the technology to handle this
distributed of production is quite new I
think and so it was not employed in
Japan very much correct that is correct
yeah we did not have the technology to
deploy small scale wind turbines in
Japan or no one had yeah we didn't love
the analytics thing we did we did not
have this finest model so no one was
able to provide benefit to our customers
even though for small wind Japanese
government has said are very pretty high
feeling philatelist price which is 55
yen per kilowatt which is pretty high
but even though we did not see a lot of
small kicks scale wind in Japan so in
Japan
uh in the northern part of Japan we have
relatively well with resources or use
other part of Japan so there are still
resources maybe maybe not as much as a
US or Europe but so we need to utilize
those resources as much possible using
United winds up technology business
model so that's why typical is very
unhappy and to partner would like you
like to go in to explore opportunities
in the Japanese market okay okay so it's
really about the Japanese market more
than it is about globalizing kept codes
business model to obtain additional
revenue from the US market well actually
we are thinking about it well so we will
start looking at the japanese market
fast but uh if it goes well of course
we'd like to seek opportunities in other
asian countries aha there's i think
there's a big market in Asian countries
so of course in Europe as well so I
think there's a lot of potential market
for the school awareness generation oh
okay I was under the impression that
Japan was kind of a difficult place for
wind that you know being a very
mountainous kind of narrow set of
islands that unlike the North Sea and
the rolling plains of Germany it would
be really hard to have very large arrays
of wind turbines is my impression
correct I think that's correct it's not
easy you know in Japan to sort of doing
business but for small will I believe
that there are places that we could
saluted eyes small wings because uh it
for small wins um I understand that we
don't need as much windows the Utah big
a big turbines okay and also because
Japan is a very mountainous country we
were unable to sort of build big wind
turbines in the mountains but we can
sort of well take take the well small
business yeah anywhere in Japan
work-wise wind so
well that's we are going to sort of do
some market research and and United wins
you know optimization of location also
you know that that turns it from
expensive trial and error into something
that can be much more strategically
implemented um you've got one more slide
which is a thank you sly so let me
suggest that we move into the Q&A part
of this so how did you find United wind
youngest son how was it what was it how
did you find find out about these people
oh well we were sort of looking for
innovative companies in the US and
Europe and what we have a what this
person is absent today but we have a
gentleman called a mr. jeffrey chow who
is having experience in i guess in
venture companies and he's helping us
find right and in jeffrey will my
introduced introduction to you which I
really appreciate yeah he's really good
at the hug dig these different companies
yeah let me give a little bit of
background jeffrey is an a serial angel
entrepreneurial investor and
entrepreneur who's lived in Japan for
probably 20 years he's started at least
six companies and taken three or four of
them public so Jeffrey is is a good
person to know in this space oh ok so he
kind of helped you look around for this
then let me ask you kinda from the other
side what was your first impression when
you heard from tokyo electric power
company is this like way far away and
not in the markets we're developing what
kind of reaction that United wind have
no I think it's a great question so when
I went when I came on board I was
overseeing a lot of critical initial
initiatives and one of them was to try
and maintain focus on what we are doing
because I think as you may know well
that one of the biggest killers for
start
is trying to do too many things too
quickly and losing focus so you know
when but but it has as I said always
been part of our vision to bring our
value proposition to customers globally
so I think when when TEPCO had reached
out it actually came to my email address
first oddly enough and I you know I
think I've in my career I have actually
started companies in feed-in tariff
markets so I'm very familiar with the
feed-in tariff structures in foreign
markets and and really I think the the
interest from united wind standpoint
that that resonated to me right away and
two other members of my team is twofold
one first of all it really furthered our
mission that we wanted to take our value
proposition globally but there were two
kind of critical components to that one
is we needed to find the right market to
grow in internationally first and we
needed to find the right partner to be
able to do that with we knew that it
wasn't something that our team alone was
going to be able to accomplish so when
you have the largest utility in you know
the third largest economy in the world
calling you with interest obviously it's
a phone call you want to take and take
very seriously the the market feed-in
tariff is one that it is very lucrative
for precisely the type of turbines and
the size of systems that we are active
in so that was one that I think from our
standpoint was a big driver of interest
the the other key for us was goes back
to this strategic partnership and from
our standpoint to grow as a company
being sort of a little fish in the Big C
of utilities you need to have not just
strategic relationships but you need to
also understand how the utilities think
and it's a very different thought
process than an entrepreneurial startup
but I think there's there's things get
that can be learned both ways and from
our standpoint that's that's another key
driver for us in building relationship
with
go is making sure we internally can you
know join forces and learn how TEPCO and
frankly other international utilities do
look at their markets and foreign
markets to help see where we can kind of
fit in better okay there's one other
thing that I want to ask and then I'll
turn over the questions to the floor and
that is typically the time required to
make decisions in large Japanese
companies is a lot longer than startup
companies in the United States are
willing to wait for and I'm really
curious how things proceeded after your
first email and first phone call Oh
yamaguchi-san what was the biggest
challenge in getting TEPCO to agree to
this partnership well as you can imagine
typical is one of the most traditional
conservative big large companies which
is very slow in decision-making and as
you can imagine one of the big challenge
was to make an investment decision this
was a typical first investment in a
international venture companies well in
the past we've done investments in
international thermal power project and
that took time that was okay because we
have a lot of things to think about
risks and stuff like that but for
venture investors we knew that do we
have to act quickly so we try to best a
sort of to make the decision quickly
even though I think we I kind of suspect
i'm looking at the champion of the
project where you probably took a lot of
personal risk to make this happen stand
what about the US side how did you
manage to get the rest of the management
in United wind to learn how to talk to
this big utility do it was interested in
investing well you know I think it was
probably a much smoother process on our
side then then in TEPCO and I'm I'm
guessing there but really you know from
our standpoint the management team is is
rather small we took it to the board
fairly quickly when there was an expert
you know there was an expression of
interest and we we kind of smoked it out
a little bit and found how sincere it
was had a couple conversations TEPCO
visited our office a few times and and
you know along that that path you know
it really in my opinion it actually to
me didn't feel like it was very slow and
bureaucratic I mean I was rather
impressed with the speed that we saw it
was I would say a few month process
which in the VC space isn't unheard of
for for investors to you know identify
diligence and make an investment so we
were we were happy with that and like i
said i think there's there's a lot more
ahead for us to explore but really i
think being in tepco's backyard there's
probably more work for us to do to get
smart and learn but we're very much
prepared for that challenge okay great
oh why don't we open the floor to
questions and I've got a couple lined up
if nobody has a question so Dan kind of
you give me the heads up if you want me
to ask one right sure I'll start your
eyes um so this question on you
mentioned in that one of your ways that
you evaluate potentially see is if
there's enough property Japan there's a
lot you know the left the property
holdings tend to be much smaller than in
in the United States so realistically
how much of a market you'd see over
there yes that's a great question and we
are work so maybe a professor Dasher and
yamagishi son did you guys hear that or
should I repeat the question why don't
you repeat the question okay so the
question was market size in Japan if I
understand correctly and what is the
market opportunity given that the the
lot size of customers might be smaller
than
and then those in rural environments and
the midwest's of the United States and
you know this goes to really where we
are right now with TEPCO in the United
States it also depends on which state
you go into really which zoning
territory and what are the setback rules
within certain municipalities so we have
to already adjust to that when we enter
a market and just as we're doing so now
with with TEPCO we are performing
diligence on we know there are actually
technology suppliers of ours in the
United States who are already in Japan
so from that standpoint vetting the
technology is a fairly simple process
getting to know the wind that sort of
core of one of the things we can do but
it's a great question on on customer
plot size and that's really I think
something that we were forming this
partnership with TEPCO and going to be
relying on them as well for for being
able to diligence certain items like
that but to the extent that they're not
as focused from a constraining
standpoint of lot size you know that
that would help but we'll have to look
at it okay thanks Dan younger son would
you comment on that the market
opportunity in Japan so it is true that
Japan is a small company as country
compared to the United States and
there's a small land and Japan is a
mountainous country but there are a
couple of quite a few well farmers and
dairies in the rural areas of Japan and
well as I said northern part of Japan
like home kinda want Oh honk ooh there's
a quite a lot of wind resources and
there are dairies and farmers are out
there and maybe in Japan there are there
could be other sort of potential
customers I don't know maybe other
factories or municipalities or even
parks you never know so that is what we
are trying to sort of do our market
research not together with palakkad wind
and we'll see what happens okay thanks
ah next question please yes
how come your company get into a workout
California California has a lot of wind
turbines California does have a lot of
wind turbines we are we find that the
wind resource in California for
residential customers is not as strong
as it is in the Midwest is one one point
it's it's a market that we're
considering in the longer term we just
see more near term opportunity in the
Midwest and the other thing California
like New York is from what I understand
it a more difficult permitting state and
you know I can say this being in New
York it is really difficult to permit in
New York yet we're doing it and part of
that is because there's a very generous
grant incentive that the state is
providing but you know in a free market
sense where we're trying to go in the
United States is where the wind resource
is strongest for us and that's rather
than it was for the time being let ya
let me follow through with Yamaguchi's
on and ask how far the permitting
process in Japan has developed for this
kind of small production I'm guessing
that a lot of the regulations may not be
clear yet hmm yeah I think you're right
we are sort of doing research as to what
kind of permitting process is necessary
for wind a small scale wins there are
several processes for utility-scale and
we we know about it but I think Japanese
or policymakers have not made a
regulation of sort of for small scale
because it we didn't have a market for
so I think we need to do some lobbying
and talk to the regulators or the local
governments so that's our job to do and
and this is one reason United win needs
a very large part
yeah okay next question yes this this is
for mr. Yamaguchi what other new energy
technologies are you keeping an eye on
that have the potential will be a
game-changer something like a new method
of coal liquification or a new method of
carbon monoxide capture or just what so
besides wind and besides pv or what are
the kind of really areas that TEPCO
Fink's are kind of hot to watch hmm well
actually what we are sort of watching is
not the renewable technology itself but
rather IT technology is that sort of
sort of utilize those are distributed
renewable resources maybe I've mentioned
before but there are no IT companies are
in the US and in Europe that sort of
that hasn't the intelligent software's
of control tvs and batteries can i
follow can with that because one of the
technical aspects of this kind of
renewable energy source is connecting it
to the grid right and i'm guessing that
United wind has to work that out with
the utility in order to deliver a
project but separate from that there are
all kinds of technologies that are
necessary of you know substation level
battery backups and this kind of thing
how does TEPCO feel about for instance
of ultras vehicles as a potential
alternative storage mechanism for power
which is in question well we are we have
started talking with the automatic
factors in Japan like Toyota Nissan
ohanga who are manufacturing are willing
to manufacture yep two vehicles because
we see that electric vehicles is can
become a great resource
factory when they are not driving you
have when they parked at homes they're
basically batteries are unutilized so it
could be used as a resource sort of to
collect and aggregate and there could be
sort of a sharing of electricity among
consumers or we could serve aggregation
sell it to the grid and there's also too
far ways that we could utilize those
resources so we are in discussion with
the automakers are at the moment ok Oh
does that answer your question ah yes no
well I think there's a Lenny chime in
because there's an awful lot of really
early stage technologies that are so far
away from commercialization the big
question is how much money utility can
afford to pay to watch of everything
from you know tidal movements and wave
movements as a continuing source of
energy to you know hydrogen and that
there are some big research projects in
Japan about hydrogen oh not just the
kind of fuel cells that are in
automobiles but in much larger
capacities and storage of hydrogen and
so forth so it's kind of a mess because
there is a lot of alternatives kind of
on the horizon but how do you and you
know if it's on how do you sort of
prioritize projects that you would
really look at to invest in what kind of
makes a really good investment project
for you as opposed to that's nice all
wait until I hear more on the news mm
well I think that a lot of new
technologies as professor mentioned but
well of course TEPCO's our R&D division
is sort of watching and doing the
research and doing development by
themselves but from my perspective my
capacity my job is a sort of look for
technology business models that will
disrupt on the energy interested in the
future so so
so so it has to be big it has to be
disruptive that's right actually I hear
that from companies that do open
innovation a lot this is one of the
characteristics you don't want just
something a little thing it's not worth
the risk but okay okay thanks oh and
yeah thanks for your question I'm not
sure we can answer to a next question
please yes I my question is around
timeline the Christian Sudan is how long
how long does it typically take for you
to install win by from say initial
inquiry from customer to actually
studying the power generation and the
question 22 yamaguchi son is it going to
be a similar in Japanese market and more
importantly when can we expect to see
the first wind turbine installed by a
united way in the in japanese market
okay then i'll let you cover that but
please restate the question for us it
was kind of hard to hear that part sure
so the the question is and i guess it
was in both markets in the US market how
long does it take United wind to go from
initial customer inquiry to a fully
operating turbine and what does TEPCO
think it will be in Japan as far as a
timeline and when when will the first
United wind TEPCO partnership turbine be
operating in Japan so I can take the
first the first piece and then pass it
along the the answer in the United
States is it depends on who the customer
is and what size turbine they are
looking for well usually the customer
doesn't know what the size of the
turbine is they're looking for it
something that United win helps them
determine based on when we look at their
utility bill one of the things that
United wind as a new company that's
really focused on growth and efficiency
has done well recently
cut down the time to go from our initial
customer inquiry to quoting that wind
lease and that used to take a lot longer
amount of time we've managed to compress
that and then we've managed to compress
the component that goes from customers
initial first quoting the wind Lee's to
getting them to sign it and part of
that's driven by we we went out and
actually hired from NRG one of the
larger unregulated utility arms here in
the United States the sales team
starting with the guy who ran all of
sales for United States and they were
focused on doing the residential model
where they would go sit at the kitchen
table and would do the once it closed in
wind it's a little bit harder to do that
so the actual sales component can take a
couple weeks but that's down from I
would say a couple months so that's
shortened and then as far as getting
equipment to cite you know that that
usually can take about well the full
development timeline can take a couple
months the actual construction timeline
maybe a week to three weeks so you can
you can talk about within a three-month
period to four-month period a customer
can have you know from the first time we
talked to them to a system operating it
depends on the local permitting laws and
so forth which in Japan we're still
dilijan Singh but Yamaguchi said I guess
I'll let you comment if you have any
thoughts in Japan and well Yama good son
is getting ready to comment can I ask
you dad do you have to do an
environmental impact report every time
you talk to a new customer or is there a
way to shorten that process because i
know there's concern about you know
birds being caught by the turbines and
that kind of thing yes so the size of
the system i think is what drives
whether an environmental impact
assessment is required for the portfolio
that i put on the screen for new york
that is not required those
fairly small their 10 kilowatt size
systems they're below the FAA
requirements in the United States so
from that standpoint it's a pretty
simple process I think we're and in
Japan this lucrative feed-in tariff it's
it goes up to systems that are 20
kilowatts in size and then the tariff
drops a little bit for systems that are
larger than that but the bottom line is
you know in the US if we go up in size
we may end up facing that I can't speak
for Japan I guess as to whether there'd
be an impact assessment required okay
younger son yes so on United wind and
Epico has just started market research
in Japan and we're sort of aiming for
the first project in Japan well sometime
next year but what we expect a lot well
a lot of challenges like they could
deploy MIT local permit issues or
regulatory issues there are some other
processes so there are challenges to
overcome but we are maybe for next year
and typical will try to move quickly as
possible okay at least one thing about
partnering together is the connection to
the grid should be a problem you can
solve together as opposed to just having
a customer relationship or some sort of
a permission relationship from the grid
operator oh I can imagine that's a
challenge for United wind yes certainly
in the the US market without any utility
partnership we are required to you know
work with the utilities in those
locations in the US if it's a a co-op
utility versus an iou you coops are not
regulated by you know the government and
in terms of being obligated to purchase
renewable energy whereas iou's are and
so the inter connection process for
example in New York is actually fairly
simple because we're selling
22 iou's or three I use and those guys
are obligated to take renewable energy
whereas when you're dealing with a co-op
in the Midwest we feel that the
interconnection challenges might be a
little bit more challenging however the
building permits side is going to be a
lot easier because putting up a hundred
and forty foot tower in the middle of
Kansas it doesn't raise as many eyebrows
as it does in New York so you know it
kind of is it okay I have a couple of
quick questions first one too
yamaguchi-san you mentioned that in
20-30 probably renewables will make up
around twenty to twenty-five percent of
the energy in Japan and I'm curious is
that a physical limit or do you think it
could achieve even a larger percentage
of the energy produced in Japan or do we
are are we waiting for a new technology
to that would disrupt this or a little
more on the 20 30 okay well this is a
government target this twenty percent
bhakta in other countries like UK or
Germany they have more ambitious goals
like eighty percent of fifty percent
total energy mix so I think Japan could
attain that goal but i think the the
constraint would be as you mentioned the
the grid constraint because we have a
sort of a week grid we have a sort of a
week inter connection in Japan we need I
think we need to sort of upgrade the
transmission system as well as a
distribution system in order to sort of
a more renewable so so okay okay and a
quick question for Dan uh would you mind
comment commenting on the troubles that
Solar City has had with a similar
leasing model and the kind of TV side of
things they're looking very well what's
been their problem Wow well they I guess
you know it depends how you look at it I
mean
II so I've come from the solar space as
well so I've done a lot in solar and a
lot in wind utility scale and
distributed United wind is my first
distributed wind platform but the
similarities between solar and wind are
the two biggest drivers for companies in
these spaces are your capital costs and
your your your capex to build a project
and your cost of capital and time and
again I've seen this happen where
development teams get very excited and
they go out and they partner with a
private equity firm and they think it's
fantastic because they have all this
money and the private equity firm is
sucking all the juice out of the orange
so you you really need I think when you
when you think you know and every
company is trying to drive down the
costs of the installation and United
wind is doing that very well the nice
thing is is our software assessment tool
is a real natural barrier to entry
because it took a lot of time to develop
it can work globally it can help us grow
and it prevents others from being able
to do it whereas going and screwing
panels into a roof and using the solar
radiance data that exists publicly is a
little bit easier I think Solar City is
a good example of what a lot of you know
these types of customers have gone
through where there's just been rapid
growth and this is a more public market
and I'm more of a private market guy so
I'm speculating here but you know I
think a lot of companies went public
with these vast growth expectations and
they weren't able to fulfill them the
you know capital intensive nature of
these industries is tough it's tough for
VCS to continue to fulfill funding
obligations with the requirement of
returns that they have so there needs to
be a transition and I think that's one
of the things again you know coming to
the the institutional capital that
United wind has behind it is you know I
wouldn't say that it's cheap capital we
obviously have
investors with with strong return
requirements that we intend to fulfill
but i think the other pieces is that
they're real institutional strategic
players so we have a lot of a lot of
strategy we say in our boardroom with
you know with the investors and so so I
think that helps us understanding that
the growth and trajectory that we're on
and really that we're in a capital
intensive business model and we need to
have an appropriate cost of capital to
be successful in doing that thank you I
really appreciate you sharing your
perspectives on that let's open the
floor to a less open questions to
another one from the floor yes oh I got
your little late so if you've already
gone over what I'm gonna ask you pardon
um I just wonder you're a small company
and TEPCO's very large company and when
you started to structure your
negotiation uh you know what I need to
talk a little about that I mean before
you guided by initial your lawyers or
you both had your own ideas and they fun
side it or you had ideas and they didn't
coincide at all and now the lawyers do
so did you guys hear that in Japan but
not too well it should repeated that be
sure so so the question was when when we
were first connected was it guiding the
discussion was or maybe make sure I'm
phrases correctly hood well the
structure of the deal the structure of
the deal was it something that United
wind and TEPCO came to on their own or
did we have assistance in doing it and
or do we have our own ideas that we
brought to the table yeah was that easy
to ride that horse it wasn't easy to
kind of get to to the agreement I guess
I'll give United winds perspective and
would pass it over yamaguchi son to to
your thoughts I mean United winds
business model has been what it's been
for for several years now and and that
really is to go out and develop and
manage and own these assets and just
grow that platform globally and I think
you know TEPCO came to United wind
really expressing an entry
in that particular model and how it
could apply abroad and and at that time
United wind was in a situation where we
are growing very rapidly in the United
States but we do have on the horizon
goals to grow abroad so I you know there
really wasn't there wasn't friction it
was very sort of cordial our goals
resonated with their goals our system
how we wanted to proceed and really you
know the partnership is is is just
beginning here as far as we're kind of
doing diligence abroad to see how the
market is but we didn't have to change
our business model in order to to court
TEPCO we did it no siree so so TEPCO has
invested into United wind and I had a
slide showing yet ish aliso United wind
has is backed by several key strategic
investors TEPCO is one of them statoil
out of Norway and total out of France
and inform Equity Partners out of Canada
so that's so it's really a venture
capital investment and it's a not a
direct investment in in the sense that
TEPCO gets management control in any way
right that's correct no it's a it's a VC
their their investor among investors
within the corporate entity okay were
there adjustments that TEPCO had to make
yummy goods on in order to to work with
the business model that if United wind
has um well so this was a sort of a not
a big investment for typically it's a it
was the first investment bench
investment for us so we've got used to
it so this is a first small investment
and so telcos objective was to sort of
learn
go to the winds platform and to seek the
possibility of a joint venture business
in Japan so that was objective and so so
there's a basically a partnership so
there was one a big negotiation you know
I was very smooth and I was just the
biggest challenge as i said was kept
causing total internal decision-making
process so we there's a possibility that
we will form a joint venture in japan
but it's uh depends on the market
research that we have just started ok ok
thank you oh let's go to another
question are you good i like to follow
up with what's your ass no are you going
to have a partnership in terms of profit
sharing in the Japanese market how do
you structure it and also in terms of
technology transfer ownership that type
of thing in your deal how do you
structure the deal yeah we couldn't hear
that too well there is a dude repeatedly
sure so so the question was is the
partnership structure how does the
partnership structure to account for
profit sharing and technology sharing
and so forth and you know the reality is
as young maybe some just said in in
Japan right now there's market diligence
that's going to be taking that that is
taking place once we get the results of
that diligence we then would enter into
specific sort of market partnership JV
structures based on what that that's
telling us so we haven't identified that
what TEPCO has done is made an
investment in the corporate entity and
therefore like any other shareholder
will enjoy the benefits of you know
United wins value growth okay thank you
next question the other direction
towards the technology right now
appears that you are experts in
horizontal axis generation technology
considering Japan's topography and the
issues there is it possible that you
might try to develop not become a
solution for involving vertical wind
generation technology so the questions
yeah the question was given the
topography in Japan would we consider a
vertical turbine technology to to deploy
in the Japanese market given the
topography okay I don't know yet she
says the brief answer from united wind
standpoint is we're technology agnostic
so we have you know we take what is the
best commercially proven technology and
deploy it because it has to be bankable
and financeable to the extent the rd
team at TEPCO has thoughts that you know
we can leverage I think we would look to
them obviously to see what their oh I'm
a good son and following up this
question let me ask if tepco's out
production partners for instance the the
makers of the turbines in Japan are they
aware of this partnership have they
talked to you at all or is it still too
early well the production partners we
have the big utility-scale wind turbines
we are partners for that but for small
small turbines I think only not nervous
are different and well there I think
some manufacturers and uninstall is in
Japan but the week we haven't worked
with them before okay all right so this
really will be market development from
the very first study right okay next
question did you have any more
it looks like there might be a
cost-benefit analysis required to do see
that oh yeah there's some work yeah any
interest in offshore wind oh so the
question was is there any interest in
offshore wind i'll let you know Gucci 7
respondus given the location in Japan uh
well I know that there are a lot of
offshore winds in Europe like in the
North 3 or where there's a lot of wind
and shallow shallow sea but in Japan
there are very few shallow seas and
their issues of fishermen's and stuff
like that so it's very difficult to have
an offshore generation in Japan although
there's some offshore generation in Ho
Chi al Qaeda which is northern part of
Japan but we don't have a big resource
for offshore generation in Japan yeah
the ocean drops off very quickly um let
me ask kind of one final question and
that is if this is really successful
what would you like to see five years
from now in this partnership will you be
mostly developing the Japan market or do
you think that TEPCO and and United wind
will be jointly developing third markets
in some of your international activities
Democrats on we'll ask you first so this
is a just a possibility but the relaxed
Explo markets in a asian countries too
[Music]
well age is big and I don't know where
to start with but you know we'll start
with Japan and see what happens and and
I think about the age of opportunities
as a next next step okay then what will
make this a real success for United wind
what would you like to see in five years
that's a great question i would like to
see you know obviously it depends on the
the market diligence that comes out of
TEPCO but you know that additional
incremental 10 10 gigawatts that is
coming out over the next 15 years you
know to capture
a good portion of it through the
partnership in the next five years and
maybe be having two or three more
countries in Asia where we could be have
having started a similar research on
those market opportunities leveraging
what we've learned in Japan okay I think
that's a good note to close our session
today thanks for everybody in the
audience for coming even though it's
raining and if you would please join me
in thanking our two speakers today
you